Good afternoon. So it's 12:30 and it says to start with the
chair introduction. It gives five minutes, but I'm not going to talk through five
minutes,
so I'll just make a little bit of time for anybody who wants to come in.
We have a great session today with Eva Hernando
and Georgina Long and myself talking about
advances in melanoma
from the basic science to clinical and then what else we think is on the
horizon.
So there's a QR code there in
the slide. You can scan that if you want to
send
questions. But it's a small room, so if you're here
in the room, there's two microphones.
They ask that you go to the microphones to ask the questions because this is being
streamed, and it will be rebroadcast, so
people want to hear you.
So I don't think I have anything else to say.
I hope you're all having a great conference.
I think we're going to get started so we're not rushing, have enough
time. And my friend, Eva Hernando Monje, she's going to be
talking about advances in basic science melanoma research.
Eva.
Thanks a lot, Tony. Thank you all for being here.
Today, I'm going to give you a
brief overview of what we have learned in melanoma
metastasis over the past few years as a field.
So, as you know, in melanoma, melanomas have to
migrate from the epidermis into the dermis, where they encounter a lot of
other cells in the stroma, the fibroblasts, the immune cells, before
entering into circulation, before being able to survive in
the shear pressure of the hematogenous spread, as well as the
lymphatic spread. Then finally, they can extravasate and seed
other organs. This is the process of metastasis.
And in the past, we used to think of metastasis as a
linear progression in which cancer cells had to gain
subsequent mutations or chromosomal alterations in order to
become fit or able to extravasate and
disseminate. And this model assumed that there was sequential
maturation and that tumors eventually were
genetically homogenous. However, the prevailing model of
metastasis that applies probably to most tumors, including
melanoma, is this parallel progression model in which
the evolution happens really fast and the ability of the cancer
cells to escape from the primary tumor is really
happening early, even from early lesions, from hyperplasia, it has been
shown. And these cancer cells are able to now
arrive to the distal locations and continue migrating,
continue evolving in a way that is different from the
primary site. So these metastasis are
genetically heterogeneous. So the evidence that supports that
melanomas undergo early dissemination comes
from the clinical evidence as well as from genetic evidence.
So as we know, melanomas are very tiny tumors, less than two millimeters
in some cases, that after complete removal, with
no margins, can give rise to metastasis at distal
sites in different organs. And this implies that at
the time of resection, some cancer cells, some melanoma cells, were already
able to abandon the primary tumor and reach
distal sites. So this is a clear model of early
dissemination. On the other hand, next generation sequencing has
shown that primary tumors gain additional
genetic alterations in parallel to those that are acquired at
the distal sites. So this suggests that there is a
site-specific parallel evolutionary trajectories that can occur
early on.
The important
evidence, therefore, is that metastatic competence is acquired early, and the
tumor evolution proceeds in a branch and sometimes organ-specific
manner. So,
there are two models of metastasis.
One model suggests that
for melanoma, the majority of the cancer cells, the majority of melanoma cells,
have a high intrinsic metastatic potential, and
this model suggests that only those cells that undergo the
appropriate organ-specific adaptations will succeed and form
metastasis. The alternative model is that only
specific specific cells within the primary tumor have the capacity to
metastasize. Only subpopulations defined by distinct
transcriptional, epigenetic, metabolic, or phenotypic states are
able to be efficient in metastasis.
And the group of, for instance, Chris Marin has shown that a
population of mesenchymal cells that carry this gene called
PRDX1 have higher metastatic potential.
And previously, the group of Sean Morrison had shown that cells that have
high MCD1 levels
were able to also metastasize more efficiently.
Probably the truth lies in between these two models, and perhaps
metastatic competence is really distributed along a continuum of
cellular states rather than strict binary distinction.
So, how melanoma cells evolve, how they become
heterogeneous and acquire all these different
features that allow them to metastasize.
We know that the stroma is a very important
determinant of dedifferentiation.
The group of Tony Rivas, for instance, show that interferon is able to induce
dedifferentiation in melanoma, and also TGF-beta has been shown to be
important for this dedifferentiation and metastasis.
The dedifferentiated cells don't regulate antigen presentation pathways,
and they create somehow an immune
shield before entering circulation.
The group of Marisol Soengas over the years have shown that
Midkine signaling also actively reprograms these local
macrophages. And
along this path, also the cells, the cancer cells, the melanoma cells have to
secrete factors such as VEGF and Semaforins to shape
these networks of both lymphatics and
blood vessels to be able to overcome hypoxia.
So in this table, I have summarized a number of microenvironmental
stressors that the cells have to encounter during these different stages of
metastasis, and which are the genes that have been shown to be involved in these
different stepsTogether with the functional outcome.
Of course, I don't have the time to go over everyone, but I'm going to
just mention a few of these. The first one, which was
reported by the group of Richard White, is this interesting mechanism in which
melanoma cells, as soon as they transform,
they start producing GABA. This is a neurotransmitter, and the
production of GABA from these emerging melanoma cells
disrupts the electrical circuits between the melanoma cells and the
keratinocytes and makes the melanoma cells now independent and able
to disconnect from this structural constraint.
We all have heard about the importance of phenotypic switching.
So we know that metastatic potential requires
dedifferentiation. This comes from the earlier studies, the seminal
studies of Hoeckerl in the Demler Lab that show this
grower versus grow decision to be distributed
between high MITF, low XL cells versus
low MITF, high XL cells. And we now know that
rather than this
strict dichotomy between these two states, cells go in a gradient
of
states that incorporate some of these properties, with some being
more proliferative, pigmented, differentiated, to
more invasive neural crest-like, and migratory.
We know also that additionally, other survival and stress
programs favor the adaptation of cancer cells, such as
the transcription factors ATF2 and ATF4.
Another very exciting finding over the recent years has been the
evidence that the mechanical confinement and the extracellular
matrix
determine the adaptation of melanoma cells, and they do so
in part by creating in the area in the
transition between the tumor interface and the stroma.
The cancer cells that are subjected to very strong
mechanical confinement developed this acetylated tubulin
cage that protects the nucleus from breaking upon
pressure. And one important gene in this pathway is
HMGB2, which is known to bend
DNA, stabilize open chromatin, and lock the cells
into a stress-resistant invasion state.
Melanoma cells also gain different
metabolic adaptations, and again, the group of Richard White
showed that melanoma cells can capture the lipid droplets from the surrounding
adipocytes and capture them through this receptor, the
FATP1 receptor. And this is, of course, very
advantageous for the melanoma cells because they can bypass de
novo lipogenesis, and this fuels rapid
primary growth.
The group of Ashley Verapna showed that in aged fibroblasts though,
instead of these lipid droplets, there are neutral lipids that are produced,
including ceramides, which are also captured by the cancer cells.
And this acquisition of ceramides happens with a different receptor now,
the FATP2 transporter, and it drives
resistance to MAP kinase-targeted therapies.
We know that
one of the main barriers to metastasis, as described by Morrison
and Elena Piskounova many years ago, is oxidative stress.
This is one of the most important barriers for metastasis, and
melanoma cells have to overcome this oxidative stress
to become metastatic. In a recent study, the group of Amaya
Biros has shown that cancer cells can benefit from the
surrounding
metabolites, and in one case, if they are surrounded by young
tissue, they use phosphatidylcholine, which favors
OXPHOS metabolism and metastasis to lung and brain.
Whereas if they are surrounded by aged tissue, they use ceramides, and now
they metastasize preferentially to the liver.
The migration of
melanoma cells doesn't happen in an
individual manner. It happens as heterotypic
clusters. So the group of Richard White showed
that the invasive cells surround the group of
proliferative cells, and they protect them from
oxidative stress again. And they
turn on this factor TFAP2, which is important for the
regulation of these heterotypic clusters.
And finally, of course, all of this
invasion and all of these steps of phenotypic
heterogeneity have to happen in an environment that protects the cancer
cells from the attack of the immune cells.
I have mentioned before the work of Marisol Soengas with
MIP-KIN.
We have also this year published another study where we found that
the transcription factor HOXD13 regulates both the
production of
factors that remodel the microenvironment and the vasculature, such as
PGFA and SEM3A, and also secrete or produce
CD73, which controls the levels of adenosine, which
is an important immune suppressor.
So to give you a couple of minutes of the work that my lab in
particular has been doing in this reference, we have
studied how mechanical compression modulates phenotypic heterogeneity,
and in particular, we're intrigued by the contribution that the
nuclear topology, the organization of the nucleus, can have to this
process.So Pietro, a postdoc in the lab, Pietro
Verico, has done a very extensive analysis of a
collection of cells going from melanocytic to
intermediate and mesenchymal. And we also have partially mimic
the conversion from melanocytic into intermediate by silencing
MITF and SOX10. And to make a
longer story short, Pietro
and our collaborators in Northwestern, who conducted
partial wave spectroscopy,
found that the mesenchymal cell lines have reduced
density and increased diffusion.
These are
factors, or these are metrics that indicate how compact the
nucleus is, how the chromatin is condensed.
So as you can see, this is indicative that the mesenchymal cells
have reduced density and therefore more
diffusion, less compact chromatin.
This is supported by the fact that the mesenchymal cells have reduced
heterochromatin levels, and heterochromatin is a marker of
very dense chromatin that is not expressed, that is not transcribed.
We found also that by,
similar to STORM microscopy, spectroscopy, single molecule
localization microscopy shows that there is reduction of
H3K27, sorry, H3K9 trimethyl, reduced
heterochromatin, which is also seen by chip
sequencing. We see the reduction of H3K9
trimethyl compared to the one in the melanocytic cells.
And this is even more, I think, apparent if we look at
the western blot where the levels of this histone mark are
extremely low in the mesenchymal cells.
Then we subjected the melanocytic and mesenchymal cell
lines to passage through these very narrow pores, three
microns, trying to mimic what happens during constriction when the
cells go through the endothelial cells and
intravasate. And we examine the cells
pre-invasion, pre-constriction, and
post-migration by different omics platforms like
RNA sequencing, Hi-C that gives us the 3D chromatin conformation,
ATAC-seq, Chip-seq, and also different
microscopy techniques. And what we found is that
the melanocytic cells, as soon as they go through these pores,
lose the histone mark, the heterochromatin mark,
becoming more similar to the
mesenchymal cells. And this is accompanied by no change in other
histone marks, very small reduction of
MITF and SOX10, these melanocytic markers, and no
upregulation of the mesenchymal markers, axle of
EGFR. So we see that just simply the
passing through these very narrow pores
induces the repression of
heterochromatin and also reduces the density of
the nucleus. So,
when we now take cells from the upper part before the
constriction and cells that have undergone this constriction, and now
we inject them intracardially to examine their
metastatic potential, we see that the ones that were on the
other side, the ones that
had undergone this constriction, had significantly
increased liver metastasis. So,
to summarize this part, we have seen that migration through
these narrow channels does not just select for aggressive cells.
It actually confers increased metastatic potential without
altering the proliferative capacity of the cells.
And this level of squeezing or compression induces
changes in the melanocytic cells that are reminiscent of the changes that
we see in mesenchymal cells, like reduced heterochromatin,
reduced nuclear density, increased diffusion.
And this is important because then we have to think that mechanical forces that
the cells are undergoing, their
pathway to metastasis, are not just passive constraints.
They are actively pushing differentiated
cells towards a more mesenchymal-like structure,
and this endows much more physical nuclear
deformability. So it's a win-win for the cancer cells in the sense that
now they
have more deformable and flexible nuclei.
I don't have the time to present all this data, but we have shown that in the
conversion from the
melanocytic to mesenchymal cells, the nucleus gets relaxed, the chromatin is much
more relaxed, and CTCF, which is the guardian
of the TADS, of the
transcriptional domains, is now moved from these boundaries
to the promoters of mesenchymal genes
cooperating with AP1. So we have demonstrated that
this mesenchymal state gives two advantages to the cells.
One is physical. They have much more deformability, and also
transcriptional. This facilitates the regulation, the changes in gene regulation by
the formation of new hubs. We have done a screen, so that I don't have the time to
present, but you can look at the preprint to demonstrate that
now these cells have new chromatin hubs
that contribute to metastasis.
And now I'm going to move to the next question, is like why
or is really the differentiation or the acquisition of a
mesenchymal phenotype required for tumor progression?
So we're asking also how intratumor heterogeneity
emerges and what are the mechanisms that drive it.
So in collaboration with the groups of Mayumi Ito and Markus Sauber, my colleagues
at NYU, and our co-mentor student, Paola Angulo,
we used this mouse model to study that question.
Is important intratumor heterogeneity for
tumor progression? So in this model, rather than
activating the BRAF oncogene or deleting PTEN as we normally do
from the tyrosinase promoter, we use the c-kit promoter.
And the reason for this is because c-kit is expressed in the melanocyte stem
cells, and we can synchronize,
by targeting specifically these cells, the tumor cells are
going to now migrate to the epidermis and then start
proliferating and going downwards to the dermis.
So this model really recapitulates the early stages of
melanoma genesis with the epidermal to dermal
invasion.So
when we use this model and we first of all remove the
hair, we treat the mice with 4-hydroxy-tamoxifen.
We also use a lineage tracer that allows us to separate the tomato
positive cells, which are the tumor cells.
We collected tumors at two, four, and six weeks to conduct
single cell RNA sequencing from the two fractions, the
stromal cells and the
tomato positive cancer cells. So immediately we can
see that a progression of these
tumors associates with emergence of intra-tumor heterogeneity as
per this UMAP. I hope it's going to become more clear now if we look at the
progression from zero to four and six weeks.
You can see that initially the majority of the tumor is melanocytic, is
mature or differentiated. But as we move to four weeks, we
see more mesenchymal cells. We divided them
into phenotypes to mesenchymal one and mesenchymal two,
and also a population of neural crest-like cells
emerges. And over time, the population of melanocytic cells
is significantly reduced and these dedifferentiated cells take
over.
These signatures that we defined as melanocytic, neural crest,
intermediate, or mesenchymal are very reminiscent of other
similar signatures that have been previously reported in the field.
What is remarkable, at least to me, is that in different
mice we consistently see the same pattern of emergence of
intra-tumor heterogeneity. It's really reproducible over
time. And if we look at the
tissue, you can see, for instance, here at this four-week time point,
that the majority of the tumor cells that expressed Melan-A and
therefore are more differentiated, stay
compartmentalized in the epidermis, whereas the more
undifferentiated PDGF-beta positive cells
are in the dermis. Over time, these populations mix,
and no longer remain compartmentalized.
This compartmentalization suggests the possibility that the
differentiation is a result of the crosstalk between the cancer
cells and the microenvironment.
Then we use a program called, or a
software called SEINec, that allows us to predict
the gene regulatory networks that are in control of these different,
pathways of these different phenotypes, in this case, the mesenchymal one.
And RUNX1 emerge as the most significantly
upregulated signature of this most important
gene regulatory network in these
mesenchymal cells.
Also we saw NR2F2 to be also upregulated, and this is
another
gene regulatory network that we have seen associated with mesenchymal
differentiation previously. So if we cross these mice with RUNX1 flox
mice,
we can investigate if RUNX require for the establishment
of differentiation. And I hope you can see that in this upper tumor, again, we
can see the separation between the melanocytic
population, and these are very thick tumors at four weeks.
However, if we cross these mice with RUNX1, you no longer
see these thick tumors. They're much thinner, and the majority of the
tumor remains in the melanocytic state.
So this demonstrates that RUNX1 is required for the emergence of
intra-tumor heterogeneity, and we have found with different epigenomic
analyses that RUNX1 controls an entire signature of genes
required for mesenchymal and neural crest-like differentiation, including, for
instance, NGFR.
So moving now quickly to the other end of the
metastasis process, we can move now to metastasis in the brain,
brain metastasis, which is really, unfortunately, a frequent
occurrence in melanoma, and sometimes these tumors are
not responsive to checkpoint blockade.
So the field has a lot of progress in investigating the mechanisms that
drive tropism of melanoma cells to the brain, and these
include PI3 kinase activity
signaling. Increased chromosomal instability has been also shown to promote
brain metastasis. Addition molecules like L-1CAM,
neural-like features or programs have been shown also by my group and
others to contribute to brain metastasis.
Metabolic adaptations of the serine and glycine pathway, but also more
importantly, reliance on OXPHOS.
The melanoma cells that metastasize to the brain seem to
have increased dependence on mitochondrial metabolism.
We saw that previously in a study published a few years ago.
We found that the mitochondria from the brain metastasis
were elongated compared to the corresponding mitochondria of the same
patient's intracranial metastasis.
We found also that these brain metastasis have increased
oxygen consumption rate compared to their counterparts.
So this reliance on OXPHOS creates an Achilles heel
that is waiting to be exploited. So Maria, a
postdoc in the lab, and Ali, a grad student,
conducted a comparison of proteomic and transcriptomic
profiling and found that a lot of the proteins that are upregulated
in brain metastasis include mitochondrial genes or genes
involved in mitochondrial respiration, including CNDP1.
So it's associated with poor prognosis and is upregulated in brain
metastasis not only of melanoma but also of breast cancer.
So CNDP1 is a dipeptidase that cleaves carnosine, a very abundant
metabolite in the brain. And the hypothesis was that as
the cells arrive to the brain, they have to
upregulate CNDP1 to cleave carnosine and
eliminate this highly abundant metabolite that is
anti-tumorality in the brain. We found that CNDP1
levels were upregulated progressively from extracranial to cranial
metastasis, that when we silence CNDP1, we see
a dramatic reduction of brain metastasis
in different models. I'm just showing one of them.
And also in already established metastasis, if we induce the silencing of
CNDP1, we can interfere, we can block the further progression of brain
metastasis. Conversely, in collaboration with a group of Sherry
Holdman, we found that the overexpression of CNDP1-In
a very poorly metastatic model, significantly enhances
brain metastases similarly to another protein that she had found
previously to also promote brain metastases.
And is particularly observed in brain metastases, and it doesn't
promote metastases to other sites.
Silencing of CNTP1 reduces the number of mitochondria per
cell, increases the number of
evacuated mitochondria, reduces the number
of TCA intermediates, suggesting that the mitochondria is not working
properly, and also it reduces oxygen consumption
rate as well as increase in ROS.
So to conclude this model, we suggest
that the upregulation of CNTP1 protects
brain metastasis cells, and that the
targeting of CNTP1 leads to accumulation of carnosine that now
acts as a ionophore that brings copper inside the mitochondria,
induces the production of reactive oxygen species, and the
degradation of important proteins for the mitochondria.
We don't have much more time, but I just wanted to indicate that we know
CNTP1 also can cleave another metabolite in the brain,
homocarnosine, into L-histidine and GABA.
We found that the silencing of CNTP1 reduces the expression of
GABAergic
signaling, and particularly the expression of GABA
receptors. And this brought us to look at the potential
interactions between the cancer cells and the neurons.
We saw the presence of synapses in the proximity within the
cancer cells and the axons of neurons.
And we have done some electrophysiology analysis that suggests that the
homocarnosine, that is the substrate of CNTP1,
contributes to electrical signaling in the brain microenvironment.
So this suggests that CNTP1 not only shields the cancer
cells from metabolic stress, but also can contribute
to this tumor-neural metabolic competition.
Of course, these are not the only mechanisms.
In recent years, there has been really an explosion of studies
demonstrating different mechanisms by which the cancer cells
interact with the microglia, with the astrocytes, and how they
hijack this stromal microenvironment to their benefit.
I hope I have convinced you that all these adaptations that cancer cells
undergo in the primary site or in distal sites,
they can also be targetable dependencies.
So one could envision the possibility of targeting physical states by
blocking chromatin hubs to prevent the initial dissemination.
We could reprogram the disease-associated or
Alzheimer's-like microglia to enhance response to
checkpoint blockade, or we can target this dependency of
OXPHOS.
With that,
I want to indicate that the same barriers that cancer
cells overcome during this process are also the
architects of its own targeted vulnerabilities.
With that, I want to thank all the members of the lab who have contributed to these
studies.
It doesn't move anymore.
And particularly, I want to thank my collaborators
at NYU and at other institutions, and the
Metastasis Research Network, which is the initiative from the National Cancer
Institute that has funded a lot of these studies. And I'll stop here.
Thank you, and I'm sorry I'm
over time.
Thank you. I found this as a great presentation.
It's really remarkable how you made these slides and summarized the field and
presented your data. We have time for one or two questions.
I'll start by asking one. So
the cells on your two chambers
study, the cells that go from one site to the other and
become phenotypically mesenchymal, what other gene
programs do they change to being able to
metastasize more?
Yeah. So we are very interested in understanding what are the
changes. So they have a trend to an increase in the
conventional mesenchymal pathways, right?
But they don't completely become mesenchymal, so they have a lot of stress
pathways activated,
and they really just look chromosomally very
different than the ones above. So this simple constriction produces
now 3D chromatin changes that activate hubs, chromatin hubs, and
new genes become expressed. Over time, we see that they relax, but they
maintain some of this gene expression still.
They have some memory of having
gone through these
inserts.
Thank you.
Yes.
Please.
Thank you for a very interesting talk.
Is the mechanism you described the same for cutaneous as for
mucosal melanoma?
Very good. Thank you for that question.
I
only use models of cutaneous melanoma, so I cannot really say if
the mechanisms will be exactly conserved.
We know that some pathways are conserved between cutaneous and, like for
instance, their high
resistance to immune response, et cetera.
Something common to both of them. Even with the mucosal being
more resistance to
or more able to do immune evasion. But unfortunately, I
haven't worked with mucosal
models, so I cannot give you a more detailed answer.
Okay. Thank you.
I'm sorry.
I'm actually following, and it's not a question.
But I was thinking about acral melanoma, which is highly
melanocytic and progresses slowly, mostly
locally, and desmoplastic melanoma, the type of
melanoma that takes away all of the melanoma hypothesis because
it's completely dedifferentiated, does not metastasize to lymph
nodes, and if it gives metastasis, only go metastatic.
So it's a mesenchymal neural
crestmelanoma that behaves completely different.
Yeah. So this tells us that the traditional view of differentiated
or undifferentiated doesn't explain-
Yeah
... metastatic behavior.
There are rare subtypes.
Thank you.
Thank you very much, Eva.
So now Georgina Long is going to share advances in
clinical melanoma research.
Thank you. I'd like to thank the organizing committee and you,
Tony, for the invitation to speak about something I'm very passionate about, and
that is drug development in cancer, in melanoma
particularly. This room reminds me of
2006, 2007,
ASCO, for example. It was rooms probably, oop,
half this size,
and not very full for melanoma sessions.
That changed probably around 2010, I think.
And we've had a long decade of great excitement in melanoma.
But I'm going to reinvigorate that excitement in melanoma
hopefully. And I think melanoma is a wonderful
model, and I'm going to convince you all that it is a
great model, and hopefully, you can spread the message.
So this is the way I think about clinical medicine and
patient-centered cancer cures. So you could use
this for any cancer. I'm going to use these stick people
for melanoma. So we know in melanoma that about
40%, in Australia, about 40% of our patients
with cutaneous melanoma are cured or have long-term
durable control with anti-PD-1 alone.
We then know that a further probably around 10%
require dual checkpoint inhibitors.
We haven't worked out exactly who those patients are to distinguish them from
anti-PD-1.
And in the last 15 years, we've seen this tremendous
change in our clinics. On the left, I always show these photos because I think
they contrast so beautifully. You've got two young men who I
met in their early 30s, who are now well into
their 40s, cured of their Stage 4 melanoma.
Grace is on the lap of Adam, and Mia on the lap of Josh.
And on the right, you have Bert, who got a single dose of
anti-PD-1 at the age of 101 for palliative reasons,
but he was cured.
Mm-hmm.
So,
Josh and Adam,
fully working, great lives, gone on to have more children,
and their children are growing up wonderfully.
And then on the left, you have Bert, who died at 105, not from
melanoma, and lived at home for those four years
independently.
So this is the starting point. These are the durable control,
but I want to focus on the rest. These are my declarations of
interest. So I'm going to talk a little bit about how far we've come.
We've heard that over the last 15 years a lot.
I won't concentrate a lot on that.
I'll talk a little bit about what has been our barrier to
success, further success, and then how can
we accelerate drug development, which is very
patient-centered. There are points of curative opportunity in a
patient journey that we could utilize better.
And then the NEOIRINI trial, which has just opened, which I think
really demonstrates using those key ideas.
So how far we've come,
I've shown you the photos, I've shown you the paradigm, but I think
CheckMate 067 of ipilimumab combined with
nivolumab, nivolumab alone in green and then ipilimumab in
gray, really exemplifies it. In fact, we're doing so
well that we don't use overall survival as an endpoint
anymore for advanced melanoma. We need to look at
melanoma-specific survival because our patients are living so long
that they're dying of other things.
And so we have, at 10 years, a 10-year melanoma
survival, specific survival, of
more than 50%, which is tremendous.
Tremendous success.
We also know that these drugs are active in the brain.
I'm showing you the ABC study because it's a small study, but it's the only
randomized data that demonstrates the difference between
ipilimumab combined with nivolumab.
This is the seven-year data where we see a nice overall survival of
50% with a flatlining of those survival curves.
And you'll see on the
x-axis, I'm not using months, I'm using years,
versus nivolumab alone in untreated
asymptomatic brain metastases. So what are the barriers
to success over and above where we are today?
I'm not going to answer that question.
I'm just going to give you an example for you all to think about
and to ponder, which we in the field are constantly doing.
So here are five drug therapies.
Epacadostat, an IDO inhibitor. TVEC, an
oncolytic virus. Bempeg, a pegylated
IL-2 compound. Lenvatinib, a
multikinase inhibitor, particularly VEGF, and then a
vaccine against PD-L1 and IDO.
And if we look at their Phase 1, 2
overall response rate,
now I want you to note, so I've put the trials, these Phase 1, 2
trial names there, that four of the
five are response rates in
treatment-naive patients, and they
seemingly look high, but they're in small numbers of patients, which I've put
there.
So then Phase 3 trials
went on after these results, and these are the
progression-free survival curves with
the hazard ratios and the P values, all negative.
A massive failure, except for two trialsAnd I
think the T-VEC trial, which was in a very
unselected stage four population, you can see it's not
significant. But we know that T-VEC single agent does have
a survival benefit. And then the other one is the vaccine
trial, where we see a little bit of a separation of the curves.
Regrettably, we actually see a detriment with nivo plus
IL-2 compared to nivo alone. Pembro plus
lenva at the first analysis, it was actually positive for progression-free
survival, but in time with the overall survival
switching. So what are we doing wrong?
And that's something to ponder. But these were massive failures.
Five trials, massive failures. Let's move to
earlier stage melanoma. So stage three melanoma adjuvant where we
resect the stage three melanoma, the bulk of the tumor, and
empirically, we give 12 months of drug therapy to
mop up micrometastatic disease we can't see.
So just showing you there, that's the goal.
And great success, again, with our lead compounds.
I haven't mentioned targeted therapy against BRAF mutations, but I
will say there are a proportion of patients that do very well
long-term on these drugs as well, probably around that 15,
20% mark. But in the adjuvant setting, we do see a
reduction with either pembrolizumab, nivolumab or dabrafenib and
trametinib for 12 months.
But we're still left with a problem, and we've got 45% of
patients that don't benefit in the adjuvant setting, and we've
tried. We've really tried. Again, three
compounds we've added to the PD-1 backbone
that have not passed muster. So CheckMate
915 with ipilimumab combined with nivolumab, relatimab
with nivolumab, and then anti-TIGIT antibody,
vibostalimab, was negative.
So there are the hazard ratios there.
And in fact, with the anti-TIGIT, we're seeing possibly a
trend for poorer survival. So what is going wrong?
I want you to note that the ipilimumab dose here,
in contrast to a study conducted in Germany
for resected stage four, which was positive, but this is a very small
dose of ipilimumab, and we know
that ipilimumab, not PD-1, has a dose-response
relationship, higher dose, better response. So again, failure.
All right. So
we still have not helped this group of patients,
which I refer to as the third space.
And that is the whole goal of everything I try to do,
both in the lab
and in the clinic, is to get to this third space.
Now, Adam is a patient of mine who was in the third space.
I had been looking after him for three years with stage three melanoma.
He had been through every treatment, diagnosed with stage four, and
died three weeks later. He was very
clearly in that third space.
Now, the reason I think this room needs to be more full- ...
is because if we can solve the third space in melanoma,
we don't have a lot of legacy drugs we have to manage,
but if we can solve that space, then we
can solve other problems.
So we can impact other cancers if we can solve the third space.
And I want to talk about our attempts at looking into this third
space. So how can we get to the third space quicker in drug
development?
So this is now the last part and the meat of what I'd like to talk about.
So the neoadjuvant platform
we know now works very well with immunotherapy.
Two doses of immunotherapy.
We then resect the tumor. We collect biospecimens
along the way, and I wanted to point to some of the work in terms of
the microbiome that was presented here at AACR.
If you get a chance to look online, Rebecca Simpson is the first
author on some of that work. Beautiful
homogeneous population of patients.
And then our pathologists look at the pathology and let us know
whether patients have TCs, tumor cells, less than 10%
tumor cells remaining, which is a major pathological response
versus partial or no
pathological response.
And the beauty is that if you've had immune checkpoints and you're a major
pathological responder, you don't actually need any drug therapy.
So it's a wonderful quality of life.
But they're not in the third space. They're in the first and second space.
And so the two randomized trials, which really put neoadjuvant
therapy as a standard treatment, I won't go through in detail, but the Phase
2 SWOG and the Phase 3 NADINA.
Beautiful design for SWOG. Simple
switch in the number of doses of pembrolizumab, giving three before surgery
rather than 18 after surgery. And then NADINA differs because you have a
combo, only two doses, and 60% of the
patients who had a major pathological response did not require any more treatment.
Now, what does that mean for a patient's life?
Here are the
event-free survival curves demonstrating the absolute
improvement in
outcomes for patients who receive neoadjuvant therapy.
So,
what does this mean for patients? Well, knowledge is power.
The pathological response enables the patient to know
what their likelihood of good outcome is.
So if you have a major pathological response, which is around 60% for the
doublets of immune checkpoint inhibitors, no more treatment, you know you're going
to do very well. In fact, the overall survival of these patients is near
100%.
Watch this space. There is a pooled analysis of 1,000 patients.
This pooled analysis, which hopefully will be published
soon.However, the pathological response
enables us to find that third space quickly within six
to eight weeks, so we can then concentrate on those patients
to try and improve outcomes. Now, these are patients who are not in the third
space, but just to give you a sense of how great a major
pathological response is.
This is Avril.
Her diagnosis of stage III melanoma, she went on a clinical trial called Morpheus,
which I'll explain in a minute. It just took six months out of her life,
complete pathological response.
She waited another six months, and then she had another baby.
So stage III melanoma, which 15 years ago you would not have had that
journey. She's back living her life, having her second
child, et cetera. So that's Avril.
Mark, similarly, with their baby who came after the neoadjuvant
treatment. He was on a trial called Neo-Trio, exploring immuno
and targeted therapy. And this is Matthew and his wife with
their little baby. Again, all success stories, but they're in the first
and second space.
Nature Medicine should probably be called the Neoadjuvant Journal of
Melanoma.
It really has pushed the field forward
for us, and neoadjuvant helps us identify the
third space. And we've been able to benchmark a lot of drug therapies
so that we can make go or no-go decisions.
But
there's a warning,
and this is how the anti-TIGIT plus
pembro trial adjuvantly was
commenced because in the neoadjuvant setting, they saw
a reasonable, not a great, but a reasonable pathological
response and chose to invest in an adjuvant trial immediately on
a small number of patients. But I'll explain how you use these benchmarks.
So we've benchmarked all these drugs.
I've asterisked drugs where you have to be careful
because we know that the major pathological response is not as
beautifully correlated with relapse-free survival
as we see with immune checkpoints, and that's intralesional therapies
and targeted therapies. They still do better with the major pathological
response. But for example, we want to know with dabrafenib and trametinib
that neoadjuvant major path response in this group, 30%
can still recur. It's not the same flatlining.
Anyway, if you have experimental drugs A and B, you can look at
the path response rate and you can make go or no-go
decisions. DONOMI trial was a beautiful example of that.
This is again, a collaboration between Melanoma Institute Australia and
NKI, driven by Christian Blank, this particular trial.
You can see pembro, we usually see a path complete response
rate of 20% to 30%, any path response
around that 35% to 50% mark and when we added an HDAC
inhibitor, and this was in high interferon gamma
signature at baseline. We're not improving on the nivolumab.
So the DONOMI study was a beautiful example of a no-go decision.
However,
what you must do, and I want to talk about this collaboration with
Genentech. Beautiful
collaboration, very responsive to our
discussions about how to proceed, but this was a trial of
four different neoadjuvant drugs.
A bispecific PD-1 LAG-3.
Again, the bispecific combined with anti-TIGIT, PD-L1 with
TIGIT, and then a control arm of nivo plus ipi
medina style. And what you can
see very immediately is that we're not really improving on the
major path response rate of ipi/nivo in this randomized study.
But what was great about this, which differed to the development of
the anti-TIGIT vibe was
that no decisions were made about drug therapies
until the translational baseline data was looked at, and that is
key. So here we have the two most active arms, the standard
ipi/nivo, and then we have the bispecific.
But if you look at the two populations.
Again, more numbers here. Just take a look at the BRAF mutation
status and the tumor mutation burden.
You can see that you've got a higher number of patients with tumor mutation burden,
and you've got a higher number of patients with V600E, and
we know that PD-1 alone in V600E
mutation patients is not as effective.
So even though this was a bit less, you've
still got some markers which suggest that this should be even
better than ipi/nivo. And this enabled Roche to make a
decision not to proceed with the bispecific within
melanoma.
So very powerful.
I also want to turn to, again, baseline biomarkers.
Just an overview. I'm not showing much translational data because I knew I was
sandwiched between two greats in terms of translational
data. But the PRADO study, biomarkers at
baseline, they are about
predicting response.
So here, just simple biomarkers, interferon gamma, PD-L1, tumor mutation
burden, high versus low, the three-year survival
estimates. But if you are high in all three, your
three-year event-free survival and overall survival is 100%.
But that's not looking for the third space.
That's looking for the responders, the first and second space.
So what we've done is we now have a suite of prediction
tools, which you can see online there, but we are
absolutely focused on the third space and have created a test we call
NeoPredict, which is about predicting resistance,
not response, resistance to
PD-1 monotherapy.
Now, that might say, "Well, aren't they the same thing?
You're predicting response, predicting resistance.
Aren't they the same?" No, they're not.
The threshold of the test changes when you set it at looking
for resistance. So it has several features, clinical
expression, gene expression, DNA, and these are chosen because we
want a quick turnaround. These patients come into our clinic, we want to know
that they're in the third space at stage III quickly.
So this is called NeoPredict.Now how can we use this?
How can we identify the third space and develop drugs quickly in the
third space so that we're not doing it after patients have progressed through
three lines of treatment when they're not as fit as they
would be?
And the patient group is not as homogeneous.
So we take our stage three patients, we perform our NeoPredict.
If they're predicted to do well, you get the standard treatment.
If they're predicted to do poorly, they're in the third space right there
before we've even started drug therapy.
We then have an opportunity for a neoadjuvant novel therapy.
Only two doses, collect the tissue, translational work is
right there. If you've had a major pathological response, you go on to
surveillance. If you've had no major pathological response, there's a second bite
in the cherry six to eight weeks after treatment.
You're in the third space still, so more opportunity.
We can then try an adjuvant trial. We can try a tumor-informed
vaccine or other immunotherapies.
If you then recur, you're in the third space again, but it's still early.
We then have another test we do, not so much for
these patients coming in this way, because we know biologically they're
in the third space. They've failed now two treatments.
But if you come to us with stage four disease, we do our
PIP test, which is basically a more detailed version of
NeoPredict. It was actually the parent of NeoPredict,
and this is driven by two great scientists in our
lab,
James and Juba.
And it has many more
characteristics. Sorry,
poor timing
.
And we now have generated a report, which we're working on,
and we're doing implementation science on that.
Excuse me.
That's all right.
Meaning
we look at the patient feedback and the clinician feedback on
this test and how worthwhile it was.
I'm good.
Yeah, take a moment.
Do we have time?
Yeah, we have plenty of time. We're doing-
I think I have plenty of time to sit here and cough at you, but something got
caught in my throat. Apologies.
So,
back to this vicious cycle of success.
You're just going to have to bear with me with this croaky voice.
I feel fine, so don't feel sorry for me.
So now we have another opportunity.
This is the third bite in the cherry.
If you're newly diagnosed, we know that you're in the non-third space
or you're in the third space because we predict you're not going to respond.
And then you have more opportunities here.
Now TILs,
T-cell therapy, very important. We do have a phase three
trial that does demonstrate a benefit against ipilimumab,
but getting the infrastructure up and running with the
genetically modified TILs, we will see greater
opportunities to look at cell therapies in melanoma.
So lastly,
we're putting this in practice,
the NeoIreni trial.
So we're now using NeoPredict. I've put the NeoIreni
NCT number at the top. We've got 10 patients enrolled.
We opened only about four to five weeks ago.
Cohort one is treatment naive. We do NeoPredict.
If they're predicted to do well, we randomize them to two
arms,
NADINA or pembro alone. We're trying to answer the question,
do you actually need the ipilimumab in this setting? So that answers that.
If you're in the third space, at the moment, remember, this is just
framework testing, we randomize to four arms, which
actually is a really important question for the field to answer.
And that is,
do you need higher dose ipilimumab combined with PD-1, or would triple
therapy suffice in this group? So we'll answer that.
We also have the control arm of the NADINA, so small dose ipilimumab,
and we have PD-1/LAG-3. So in this small study,
we will answer a question that has evaded the field for the
last 15 years.
If you have a major path response, you go on to surveillance.
If you don't have a major pathological response, you have adjuvant treatment, but
there's an opportunity to go on a trial.
We also have two further cohorts in this trial.
Cohort two is the third space. These are patients who have progressed on
anti-PD-1 or neoadjuvant NADINA or pembro.
They are randomized to three arms, again answering that question in the setting of
PD-1 failure, what combo works best?
Again, note that anything in red, we can plug in
any novel drug therapy we like.
And then lastly, we have a mucosal melanoma cohort,
neoadjuvantly so that we can collect tissue.
So it's a vicious circle of success in terms of collecting tissue
for people in the third space if you don't get a good response to
understand what next moves.
We already have an additional three drugs lined up for this space here
that are novel, but this is about getting the infrastructure and the
thinking into the clinic so that every patient, our goal when we
first meet them is, are you in the third space?
So,
these are some of the drug therapies that have been discussed at this meeting, that
are discussed at every oncology meeting.
We have 22 recruiting trials. I just wanted to make note
that this is Adam, who was in the third space.
So is LukeLuke
progressed straight through PD-1 and then PD-1 plus high-dose
ipilimumab, and we were able to put him on
a self-replicating mRNA. It was intralesional, and I just
wanted to point out this is single agent,
truly third-space patients, and we're seeing pretty
significant activity, and that's what Luke is receiving at the moment.
He's doing well 18 months down the track.
But there are many other ways that we can attack the third space, and that we
are
with various different success rates at the moment.
But I just wanted to highlight that all of these are in
our toolbox for the third space.
Now, lastly, the point about
helping other cancers. What we learn in the third space in melanoma
absolutely will impact other cancers.
First of all, all the drugs developed in melanoma first
are now the most ubiquitously used drugs across cancer.
So anti-PD-1 is a good example of that, as is BRAF/MEK.
Anything that we develop in melanoma ends up being impactful in
other cancers, and I think that will continue.
This was published last year. This was using neoadjuvant triple
immune checkpoint
therapy in glioblastoma, a single case.
So you can't put much in terms of survival as a single
case, but it's about the thinking.
It's about changing the thinking in cancer.
So this patient received triple
immunotherapy and then had a resection.
Basically, to summarize that paper, we saw a 10 times increase
in T cell cells, but I mean T cells, CD4 more
than CD8. They were newly activated.
They were not activated at baseline.
And we saw an increase in T cell clones, diversity, but
without dominance of a clone. And I just wanted to highlight there's a whole
aspect here of the peptide vaccine that was used adjuvantly, which is about to
be published.
I won't go through it in detail given the time and my
throat that interrupted it. But Helen Rizos and I
selected 10 peptides for this vaccine,
five neoantigens and five ERVs. Very
exciting data that I won't go through now, but
watch this space for vaccines. So it really does--
We are not in silos, and we should all be working together in cancer.
So just to summarize, how far have we come?
We've got the 10-year melanoma-specific survival more than 50%.
What is the barrier to success? It's resistance, and it's an
ongoing investigation.
But we've got to do better when we plan from phase one, two to phase three
studies, and it's going to be in the tissue.
That's where the answer is. Accelerating drug development for
patient-centered care, it's really an ecosystem, and it's a
mindset. We start early with neoadjuvant, and we keep
trying bites at the cherry early in the course of the
patient's journey. The neo-IRENE trial is open and
really exemplifies that thinking, and it's about building the
system so it becomes part of the patient care.
And I just wanted to point out that we're now doing neoadjuvant.
I've spelt neoadjuvant incorrectly there, excuse me, but Neo-RELLA,
so PD-1 plus LAG-3 in stage two melanoma will be presented at
ASCO. Wanted to thank patients and their families for participating
in research, but also all my colleagues in the lab
and also the clinical care of patients at Melanoma Institute Australia, and thank
you.
Georgina, this was a fabulous presentation.
It's great to see all this
work that you and your colleagues have done over the years and the
work of the field summarized so well.
Well, there's people lining up, so I hope you can
answer some.
Yes, Dr. J.
Thank you so much for the talk. Wonderful.
So you said that
pathological response is not a good readout for the success
in the neoadjuvant setting. So how do you make the decision, the go, no go
decision of moving with a new drug, a
new treatment if you don't have reliable
information coming out?
Easy. It's easy. So Morpheus exemplified how
you do it, and we're doing it, and Dinomi exemplified how to
do it. And that is you've got to have the translational research
coupled with the readout from pathological response.
And every time you do that, so you take the baseline tissue
plus the readout of the pathological response, you'll have success every single
time. The problem with the Vibo, the anti-TIGIT,
was there was no investigation of the
baseline tissue before making that decision.
And that is at your peril for pharma
not taking the time because there's this race, a perceived
race, but I tell you, the
winner is the one who can get to the third space.
That will win every time. So the peril is that they don't take the
time to look at the baseline tissue and really explore
that if you're seeing a slightly higher pathological response in the
combo, is it because you have enrichment of high interferon
gamma and PD-L1 expression? So you've got to take the third space, so low
interferon gamma, PD-L1, and then compare the arms.
If you do that, you're fine. And that's what we did in Morpheus.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for your talk. I found it really interesting that at the
very end, you recall having an analogy with glioblastoma.
And so I was wondering if you can speak on any sort of new updates
on the trials with brain metastases in melanoma,
the sort of window of opportunity studies, which I know they were
maybe ongoing, or I'm not sure they're finishedBut basically
neoadjuvant immunotherapy with a subsequent
biopsy or resection to look at response.
Yeah, we did a lot of those early on.
So the ABC trial started back in, oh God, I can't even remember now,
2014 or something. But
what we found with the brain, unlike glioblastoma or primary brain cancers,
it's just another metastatic site in melanoma.
And when we've compared liver, bone, brain, lung, lymph
node, the brain is not as bad in melanoma as the
liver or the bone is, for example. So window of opportunity
and resect from the brain, we've done that a lot, but we haven't learned as much as
when we go to sites where we see a lot more resistance,
and so that would be the liver. So what I guess I'm saying, just like we have the
third space
unresponsive, any tissue, although we have to
remember the seed versus soil, so if you have a resistant lung versus resistant
liver versus resistant brain, but any of those
resistant metastases will help us, just like any
patient in the third space, although you might have three patients in the third
space, they're all different.
Anything we learn from one of them will help us.
So we're not specifically pursuing the brain, even though
the liver's worse, actually. If we can pursue the liver, I think we'll get more
answers. Just to answer that. But primary brain cancer is very different, and
that's where they should be doing-- absolutely every trial should be window of
opportunity, if they can. Some patients come in very sick and need
surgery ASAP.
But yes, so that's where I think window of opportunity in the brain really needs
to be done.
Thank you.
Two shorter questions and answers.
Very nice talk, Georgina, as always.
Thank you.
My question is around stage III, clinical stage, and how
effective is it to have stage IIIA versus D.
Does one respond better than the other?
So stage IIIA has a very low
recurrence rate compared to B, C, and D.
So you've got an inherent
difficulty in terms of long follow-up and the absolute change from a
recurrence rate of 20, 15%,
50% recurrence
reduction in the risk takes you down to 10%.
So it's more not the biology, it's more the
inherent
difficulty in measuring when your risk
is so low. But having said that,
IIIA is micrometastatic, so you don't have a bulk of
tumor. And there's IIIA and there's IIIA.
So for me as a clinician, IIIA with, say, multiple
micrometastases, maybe two nodes or lots of little deposits or both
sides when you have a central
primary or high mitoses in the primary,
I see that as a bad biology equivalent to a
stage IIID that might be racing along.
So I think the staging is a crude method of
assessing the biology, if that answers your question.
It's complicated, I think-
Yeah.
-that response.
It's complicated.
Jesse.
Thank you so much, Georgina. Beautiful talk, as always.
So lots of opportunities to attack the third space.
However, I didn't hear you talking much about targeted therapy.
So I'm interested in your thoughts about using targeted therapy as a strategy to
overcome resistance, and how we made so much progress combining
immunotherapy and targeted therapy.
Great question. Yeah, targeted therapy gets a bit of a poor rap.
I tried to say in the beginning that we are curing a few with targeted therapy.
I think the nature of targeted therapy, particularly melanoma, where you're
looking at cutaneous melanoma with multiple mutations and abnormalities,
targeted therapy is not as flexible to deal with the resistance
mechanisms. And so we just see a lot more resistance mechanisms,
as you would know very well with targeted therapies due to the nature of the
biology and the escape mechanisms around it.
It's just so complicated with so many different pathways into the nucleus.
However, having said that, I've got a little bit of hope
for protein degraders, but I still would like to activate the
immune system because I think that's the only way.
It's the most flexible way to eradicate a cancer cell.
So I guess when you're in our world and we've been spoilt
with cure,
then we're still going for cures.
And I think targeted therapies may have a
role for the low tumor mutation
burden,
mucosal melanoma, et cetera, if we can find some specific
targets. But in my hands, I've worked with so many targeted therapies, but
resistance just develops. We don't see the same durability.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
So I get to close the session, and I'm going to be
talking-- And you left something here.
I'm going to be talking about Georgina's third space.
I'm thinking about new targets that we're trying to advance for cellular therapies
for melanoma. These are my disclosures.
Please take them into account.
Some years ago, with my colleagues at
SWOG and Arie van der Walt, we designed this clinical trial where patients
who had progressed on anti-PD-1 therapy,
we thought we could reverse resistance by adding anti-CTLA-4
because it has a broader immune effect. And that did happen.
It doesn't look too impressive, but these are patients who were all progressing on
anti-PD-1. And here, the red line, the only changes that we
addedanti-CTLA-4, and there was a 30% response rate.
We've studied the patients who are resistant here, their biopsies, and
the ones who go on to respond. And here's a paper that's
just been released today. Katie Campbell is in the room.
This is the QR code. It's still on the preprint version
in "Cancer Discovery." And there you can read the
many years of studies that Katie has done on biopsies of these
patients to show what's
the phenotypes and the cell neighborhoods of biopsies
of patients who don't respond to anti-PD-1 and then they're reversible with
CTLA-4. So I'm going to
then give my biases of what is this third space
phenotype, the patients who do not respond to current immunotherapies,
either single agent or combination immunotherapies.
And the first, and
by far the most important, is the lack of immunogenicity.
If the immune system cannot differentiate the cancer cell from a normal cell,
good luck trying to turn on the immune system to cancer.
In extreme examples, very uncommon,
there can be genetic ways that the cancer escaped an immune response.
There was a very good immune response, and that cancer figured out that if you
do not express antigen presentation machinery or interferon gamma
signaling, then you can escape.
And the third most important definer of
these non-responsive melanomas is tumor heterogeneity.
As the melanoma keeps progressing, it keeps evolving in different ways.
My colleague Roger Lo has done studies on multi-resistant
melanoma with warm autopsies and
analyzed multiple
metastases at the same time. You can see this dramatic divergence
of metastasis, something that we know there's no one therapy or
combination therapies that could address.
So what I'm going to do is then how do we
think about
dealing with these? And in my opinion, and with Georgina's
outstanding summary of what has happened in the last several years on the
slide with the five randomized clinical trials that we thought
most of them were good ideas and with no benefits, that
we have to completely change the paradigm.
And I'm sorry, I want to edit this slide and add TIL
therapy, but I'm glad that John Hannon is here because John
is giving a plenary talk tomorrow, so I hope you'll stay, and you'll learn all
about TIL, and forgive me for not even putting it
in this slide. But I think that
it's not a novel target, but TIL therapy is a way to try to address
these persistent melanomas. I'm going to talk about these CAR targets
that we've been developing pre-clinically, and one of them in the clinic.
The one that's in the clinic, it's an IL-13 receptor alpha 2
chimeric antigen receptor that Christine Brown had been developing
for glioblastomas. It's a decoy
chain of the IL-13 receptor. It behaves like a
cancer-testis antigens, and in some cancers, it's
re-expressed, like glioblastomas, with some responses in
Christine's work. Anusha Kalbasi, who was a postdoc in the lab and
now is a faculty member at Stanford, looked at the gene expression profiling of
IL-13 receptor alpha 2 in all cancers in TCGA.
Here's glioblastoma, and here's melanoma.
So we thought, well, maybe we could use this existing CAR to treat
melanomas, and it's a subset of melanomas, 10 to
15%, that express it. And very few express this
higher than homogeneous. That's the issue with most cancer-testis
antigens, MAGE and
others, that they tend to be patchy expression because they're epigenetically
controlled. This one has the same, so there's a lot of low expression,
which is not good, and then the high expression is very low.
But despite this, we've been screening patients for the last several years and
putting them in clinical trials.
We were awarded a California Stem Cell Initiative
grant to open a multi-center clinical trial, and we've
been
running with
patients enrolled until now, mostly at UCLA, but now they can enroll at
Stanford or City of Hope. We send the leukapheresis to
City of Hope, which manufactures for all of us.
And at
City of Hope, they will give this CAR intraventricularly for
glioblastoma. We give it systemically, so we had to start at lower dose and
then go up. Kim Margolin was involved at the setting up of this
study, and now we have Alison Bethoff, Yan Jing, and
Kathleen Fennerty as the clinical PIs on the sites.
And we've been giving it to
patients. We're on patient 19. I'm going to show you for the first patients.
And there's expansion of the CAR T-cells, brisk expansion in blood,
mostly in the first days
while there's lymph depletion, and we've tested different lymph
depletion regimens. We settled on one that's lower than
the CAR T. And
in melanoma, we've seen occasional lesions responding.
So here's a lung metastasis that responded in the PET, but the liver
metastasis progress, telling us about this tumor heterogeneity.
I'm not going to show you the latest data.
We also figured out that neuroendocrine cancers have high
homogeneous expression of IL-13 receptor alpha 2 in many
of them. So now we're putting pheochromocytoma, adrenal cortical carcinomas,
and others, and we are seeing clear evidence of
responses in that setting. So we're shifting this program
away from melanoma, where we barely found patients with
no responses at the several doses that we're finding responses in
neuroendocrine cancers.The second program I'm going to talk about
is one that would cover a lot more patients with
melanoma, and it's in the pigmented pathway, so that would cover many
of the non PD-1
responsive, rare melanomas like acral,
mucosal, and uvula melanomas that tend to
be highly homogeneously pigmented, express all of
the pigmented pathways.
TYRP1 is a protein that is in the melanosomes,
but it's apparently expressed on the surface.
We could see it for MART-1, and MART-1 actually flipped the position from the
melanosomes and inverted itself in the surface
of melanoma, the actual protein, not the peptide, that the
peptides are presented, obviously.
And then TYRP actually maintains the structure and goes into the surface
of a subset of melanomas. There are obviously the melanocytic
and transitory. This is from our paper with
Tom Graver years ago, mapping all the phenotypes of melanoma.
And these are our melanoma cell lines tested by Chris Putzaus,
and they are inverted, although these are the melanocytic that should be
here and the transitory. So there's a certain number, and
there's high expressers and low expressers.
Chris with Yvonne Chen made several chimeric
antigen receptors with CD28 signaling and
then had different lengths of the
CARs. They all work well with the
melanocytic melanomas with good killing in vitro.
The intermediate expression of TYRP is not being targeted,
which is a good safety way to tell us that there's going to be a therapeutic
window from normal cells that would express low TYRP
to the highly melanocytic melanomas.
And
one of the good features of this binder,
the antibody binder to
TYRP, is that it has cross-reactivity to mouse
TYRP1,
which then allows us to test in B16 melanoma and in vitro
it's killed really well. But then the key test is
would we have responses in
Black 6 mice, so have Black 6 mice obviously express
pigmented proteins in normal cells,
implanted with a B16 melanoma, a murine melanoma in a syngenic mouse
that we lymphodeplete and then give the adoptive transfer.
And this is very exciting data for me.
Here are the three CARs. There's this CAR with the long hinge
region that works really well. They all work really well in vitro, but you have
to test them in vivo and see which one works the best.
This is from
established B16 melanomas.
I've worked with B16 melanoma for
30 years. This is the best data ever I've seen with treating an
established B16 melanoma with anything.
And the mice
are fine. They're Black 6 mice. They just go on with their life.
They get old. They get some vitiligo, but all mice do because we
do a total body radiation, the control mice also
do. There's no differential toxicities in the skin,
the eye or the ear.
It works with human melanomas implanted into mice.
These are two of our melanocytic melanomas, 207 and
249. And you can see these really remarkable responses when
implanted
in mice. So the status of these trials that Chris has been
working for five years with a California Stem
Cell Initiative grant,
to fulfill all of the requests for the FDA that we had on a
pre-IND meeting.
She's done all of it, the IND-enabling toxicology studies,
made the clinical-grade lentivirus, has the final protocol filed,
and she's going to send an IND within a month or two.
Now we're raising the next step so we can go to the clinic,
the money to do the phase one trial.
So we hope we'll be enrolling sometime when we gain
these funds.
The last thing I'm going to talk about is completely new targets.
We've been
thinking for 10 years probably that there
may be a whole bunch of surface targets that we have not been
able to
make binders and CARs and T cell engagers and
things like this. These are triggered by
Yixing, who's a
bioinformatician and expert in splice variant analysis,
who was at UCLA and now was
recruited as the
chair at Children's Hospital of Philadelphia.
I'm working with my colleague, Ameya Champekar, with the
idea that
this alternative splicing of some exons in
surface proteins may lead to new antigens that could be targeted
with CARs.
So we tested our
repository of melanoma cell lines with different
phenotypes, 15 melanocytic, 11, 14, and nine of the different
subtypes. So we can see which are
the splice variants in these phenotypic subgroups or in known
melanomas. So
I'm saying it's a project of 10 years because for many years we had
done regular RNA-seq, and then we were
trying to map out these splice variants and then come up with the
idea that there was a splice variant, and we would try to
recapitulate that, and we couldn't find the same splice variant when we
recapitulated it. It was because the long read RNA maps
back to the normal places of the exons.
And it changed when we went to this nanopore long
RNA-seq, and we did multiple reads, 1.5
billion from our 49 melanoma cell lines.Three
melanocytic samples and then 28 normal tissues, and then we
were able to then start finding melanoma specific
splice variants. The pipeline
has been developed by Yi Xing. It's
all of these steps of trying to clean up the data and then
doing this log and read RNA, then
looking at
surface. In this case, we've done for TCR targets,
but here I'm focusing on
proteins that have a transmembrane domain and then a predicted
extracellular domain, and see if there's a splice variant in the
extracellular domain part of the protein.
And here I'm going to show you one example.
We have several that we're pursuing, but I'm really excited about this because now
we have the first evidence that we can do the whole thing.
So here's this
gene target. The normal target is this blue one that
has this exon one and then exon two.
There's an alternate promoter start and then has a different exon that
binds to this exon two, which leads to a nine
amino acid change in the extracellular domain of this protein.
Here, all of our melanoma cell lines color coded with
their phenotypic group, so it's up to this blue here.
And then there's the melanocytes, and then there's the 28
normal tissues. And we can see that the blue transcript is
a little bit expressed in normal tissues and then some melanoma cell lines.
But melanoma cell lines are the only ones that have the
red transcript and not in here. This
is if you just take the little bit, is it one or
the other? But the melanomas have more of this
transcript and expression
and ability to express it. So we thought it was a reasonable target to
pursue. But when you're pursuing
looking for
targeting a new protein, and the thing is that it's a new protein,
so nobody has ever done and made an antibody to it.
So
how do you find binders to something that nobody has looked
for?
But we turn this into a
surface display nanobody library made by Andrew
Kruse at Yale, which is
a yeast that can
express
a nanobody. And the nanobody is randomly mutated
in the CDR1, CDR2, and CDR3 regions
on these amino acids that give the highest variability
of nanobodies to bind to different
proteins. And then there's some of them that kept constant because they figure
out that those are the ones that were required to maintain the nanobody
recognition. And that makes 500
million unique nanobodies every
time we thaw the library and we activate it with galactose.
And that allows us to then,
if we have
a cell line that has the normal transcript and the isogenic cell
line that has the alternatively spliced transcript,
and we color code them, and then we grow the nanobodies and we do
multiple rounds of panning and selection
and flow sorting of the
nanobodies,
the yeast that have the nanobodies that bind from the ones that don't bind, and
they keep sorting and sorting and sorting.
And eventually, we want to look for the ones that are of the
sorted clones, the ones that bind to the
cell line that has the alternatively spliced protein, which is shown
here, from the ones that do not have the alternatively spliced protein.
And here's where with multiple rounds and showing you the
feasibility of these, here's the flow cytometry.
So here's a nanobody that does not bind
to the
regular transcript. It binds to the alternate
transcript, that's the melanoma specific transcript, and that's by
testing after multiple rounds and retests.
There's 44 clones that have this phenotype, and
here's some of the clones are actually,
for example, this clone 844 from one run of the
library. There's all the multiple clones that are the exact same
sequence of the nanobody. They're just recombined randomly in
other
activations of the
yeast displayed nanobody library.
So we took three of these and we said, "Well, those are
promising nanobodies that we should develop."
And Olivia Restifo in the lab had taken
Chris Puttcharoontang and Yibod Ngan Chen's
CAR and then prepared it to
swap the antibody from that CAR to YRP or
CD19 and CD20 to have any of the
sequences of these nanobodies so she could rapidly
test multiple nanobodies in experiments.
And
when she showed the first data
in a lab meeting of her first test of the first three
nanobodies, I could barely believe these data.
So here's the control cell line. So the
mock is the red that's here. It grows progressively.
This
nanobody kills it, so that's non-specific
answer. Am I seeing this?
Yeah, this is killing it. And these two ones are
not killing the normal control, so those are
specific
killing. And then here we have the
control cell line and all three nanobodies killing the
alternatively splice. So of the three nanobodies that kill the
alternatively splice, I should have explained it this
wayOne of them kills
the non-alternative splice or the tumor specific,
but two of them, and one of them in particular, the 844,
specifically kills the alternative splice and not the wild
type
cell line, which is, I think, really exciting.
And we have now several targets with multiple of these
nanobody campaigns to test.
So what I wanted to convey is that we cannot fix the lack of
immunogenicity of cancers. We try to with
irradiation or injecting things, it does not fix a low
immunogenicity. But we can think about new targets to
redirect the immune system and specifically bring it to the cancer.
So here's
the main people involved in this,
I've been citing them as we described, and Olivia and
Katie.
Where's Katie here? But she's in the back of the room.
And thanks to our funders and
different grants.
So I'll be happy to take any questions.
Or I'll have to ask myself a question.
"Hi, Tony, what do you think about..." Thanks.
Kim.
Saving you, Tony.
I think you said that with those
tyrosinase-related proteins-
The YRP
... T cells-
Yeah
... that you don't require lympho-depleting conditioning
for?
No, we do. So I was saying that in
immunocompetent mice, we do lymph depletion.
In the immune deficient mice, no, we just because they're
immune deficient, but yes. The clinical trial is with cytoflure lympho
depletion.
So the patients won't be as happy as those mice were.
Yeah.
Hello. Hi, Tony, nice talk. So the question is about the CAR T
efficacy. We know that from regular T cell world that
efficacy depends on the microenvironment and the immune suppressive
microenvironment, often in the non-responsive patients. What about CAR Ts?
If that's the same patient with the immune suppressive microenvironment, does the
CAR T still have efficacy in these patients?
I'm going to answer indirectly. So,
20 years ago, we learned from Steve Rosenberg how to gene modify T
cells to express a MART-1 TCR that was a very good
TCR
that would redirect to MART-1 positive melanomas.
And we had half of the patients that we treated,
talking about 20 years ago,
had very immediate responses so that the melanoma can
respond very rapidly. They progressed within three to six
months, and most of them we couldn't
confirm the responses because the progression was rapid.
But it told me that this idea that
T cell therapies cannot work in solid tumors is not
right.
TIL therapies have been demonstrated to work in solid tumors, and
it's what is the target and how good are those T cells?
So lymphomas seem to be more permissive to T
cells, and most solid tumors are less permissive to T
cells. But that doesn't mean that there's a tumor
microenvironment factor that cannot be overcome.
Yeah, but would they be then the same factors that normal T cell therapy versus
CAR T cell therapy have to overcome?
Like a myelo suppressive cells inhibitor or something like that has to be
applied to both types of therapies, right? CAR Ts and regular T.
Yeah, and
I'm sorry I tend to answer questions with my biases,
but I'm trying to be honest when I answer.
I think the most important thing is do you have a T cell that is
recognizing something in the cancer differentially?
And that T cell will start making all of the factors that you need to change the
tumor microenvironment, including the immune suppressants from myeloid cells.
If you give them a little bit of interferon gamma, your immune suppressive myeloid
cells turn on into very permissive myeloid cells.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
Georgina?
Just a practical question, and trying to apply some of this
wonderful science into the clinic, which is ultimately our goal.
And I guess it's also to John Haanen.
So looking at the ecosystem of trying to identify that third space
and get there earlier,
do you think that you could get CAR T
working so that we can test it in
biomarker-predicted third space patients as their
first treatment in a neoadjuvant setting so that you then collect the tissue?
Is six weeks? How quickly could you get a CAR T?
And is six weeks enough? And then with a biopsy, that's the first
question. We're already thinking about how to use TILs early
in terms of your path, non-response, beautiful tissue there, send that off to make
your TILs so that you can then be ready at their first recurrence.
What do you think of those practical things, thinking about the next steps?
Can we get there?
So I think the practical issue is the target.
How you target that, it can be
done multiple ways. So for us academically, it's easier to take
T cells and gene modify them with a lentivirus. We know how to do that.
We've standardized everything. It's just expensive, and we're having
trouble opening a trial that we have everything else done.
So there are limitations there. But
there's ways to take those same binders to surface
proteins and have other platforms like T-cell engagers,
you can make ADCs. And now the exciting advent of
in vivo gene editing, where you could just give the vector or a
transient LNP with RNA and genetically modify
T cells inside the patients without
lympho-depleting, and then having those T cells redirect and go to the
cancer.
There are several presentations in this meeting.
There's several recent articles.
I think it's an exciting new field, and we'll
rapidly change those platforms as soon as we think there's one
that's...
John?
Yeah. Considering your question, Georgina, yes, I think it's possible, right?
It's feasible to grow TIL in, let's say, five weeks for patients
that do not respond to neoadjuvant ipi/nivo or anti-PD-1 treatment.
But of course, it's always
a heavy treatment for these patients because it consists of
high-risk chemotherapy, TIL infusion, interleukin-2.
Maybe in the future, if other platforms
show
more promise and can be expanded to more patients,
we'll get over that. But at the moment, one of the biggest problems is the
cost of these treatments, right? We have to overcome that or do something
more clever in order to
do this. But I completely agree with you that patients that have failed
anti-PD-1 and anti-PD-1,
anti-CTLA4 are great candidates for TIL treatment, and the chance that they will
respond is about 30% or more.
Thank you very much, John. Thank you, Eva and Georgina, for great presentations and
everybody who participated in this session.